breaking right now metro police
releasing new information as they search
for the person who killed a newspaper
reporter good afternoon thank you for
joining us at 4 i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas longtime
investigative journalist jeff german was
found stabbed to death outside his
northwest valley home
saturday morning
we have team coverage this evening
victoria saha in the newsroom with
reaction from his longtime friends but
first the 8 news now i-team's vanessa
murphy live outside metro police
headquarters with new video and pictures
police want you to see vanessa
at this point it is still unknown
whether jeff german's job as an
investigative journalist is a motive for
this crime in the meantime metro police
are asking for the public's help take a
look this is the first time we are
seeing video of the suspect metro police
are saying look at how the individual is
walking what they're wearing in case you
may recognize them they're also looking
for this vehicle gearman was found
stabbed to death outside his northwest
valley home saturday morning captain
dory corrin says the crime was committed
friday morning he says police believe
the individual has been in the area
before casing the area to commit other
crimes and there have been recent
burglaries but at this point it is too
early in the investigation to know why
german was killed
metro has stated they do not believe the
public is in danger but since no suspect
is in custody yet i asked why
nothing is absolutely in our world and
we do encourage our public to always
remain alert always report suspicious
activity but as of now we believe this
was an isolated incident
metro has enacted major case protocol
due to the nature of german's work
meaning they're putting extra resources
into this case anyone with information
is asked to call metro homicide or crime
stoppers we'll have a number for you in
just a moment in the meantime i'll send
it over to victoria sahar
thanks for that vanessa um yeah i spoke
with um
there's still a lot of questions as to
why someone would commit such a
senseless act and those who knew jeff
gearman are still trying to wrap their
heads around this murder they say
gearman dedicated his career to bring
people to justice and now they want the
person who killed him to be caught right
away
back out at gearman's neighborhood near
tanaya and vegas drive there was a
police presence as they went around
talking to neighbors again i was also
talking with neighbors showing them a
picture of the person who police believe
is responsible for gearman's death the
morning of september 2nd they say they
did not notice in this individual i
spoke with george mccabe a long time
friend of gearman i showed him a picture
of the suspect and this is what he had
to say
that person's still out there right this
is the thing jeff would be emphasizing
i'm sure that person is still out
running around somewhere that looks like
somebody planning a crime to me who's
disguising their appearance and looking
to do something
bad in the neighborhood
again take a close look at this picture
this person is seeing wearing a very
large sun hat and what looks like a
utility uniform and gloves the person is
also carrying a bag
mccabe emphasized that his dear friend
would be working very hard to cover this
murder no matter who the victim was and
he wants las vegas to do the same for
him kirsten